je n'adopte pas cette expression racisme
anti blanc pourquoi parce que je sais
d'où elle vient elle vient de l'extrême
droite en france et des mouvements
politiques qui cherche à décrédibiliser
tous les anti raciste parce que si vous
en venez à dire les lilian thuram
cunningham thuram et arabes ont fait
craquer maintenant tu as peur des
environs n'a rien du 2ème basséen
charnue moi je le dis juste que je
n'entrerai pas dans votre manoeuvre
grossière moncaut règle en rien la télé
non alors écoute je préférais été
militante au moins avec allah le sait ça
au cul là c'est moi qui vous ai fait
exprès de forger cette terminologie pour
disqualifier tout les antiracistes
pardonnez-moi mais lilian thuram il a
fait un travail formidable
il a été commissaire à la commune les
jeux du quai branly avec jean studer nom
n'est pas dans la politique ce sera des
matchs donc disqualifié les antiracistes
c'est empêcher des générations et des
générations d'individus comme vikash
dhorasoo et d'autres pour se battre pour
l'égalité et c'est ça qui est contre
intuitif en fait dans cette formule les
blancs qui peut être utilisée notamment
aux états unis
aux états unis vous savez que on est
d'abord manque d'une communauté avant
d'être membre de la nation donc ça quand
on dit bien white pipeau ans aux
etats-unis c'est normal je les chairs
vous ne connais pas ce film dit white
lies pour la série des white foil les
carnations pippa pippa
mais c'est à dire que aux états unis on
est d'abord dans sa communauté avant
d'être dans la nation donc évidemment en
gestation mais en frères n'ont donc
jusque jacques ii contre intuitif à
utiliser ce vocabulaire de dire les
blancs quand en fait on incarne une
aspiration à l'égalité parce que ce que
8 h de radu lilian thuram et les autres
rokhaya diallo en sari légal ou non
intimité pour mener leur combat et la
cédant pas aux manoeuvres grossières de
l'extra crois que c'est toi même